I get those
Goosebumps I
[Music]
need what is Up Guys in today's video we
are going to be doing a money-making
method that has no requirements
technically there's a small requirement
all you have to do is just start the
giant dwarf Quest so once you start that
go ahead and run up
here travel into this little trapo thing
in the GE I'm not sure what it's called
but I'm going to call it a trapo then
ride the m cart go up
here open the door and we are going down
to where the blast furnace is and trade
this guy he sells
ores and the ones that we're interested
are the copper ore they sell for four
coins
each so I will start the timer and then
basically you just buy a full inventory
of them you run down to the bank you
bank them and then you repeat the
process and I'll be back in an hour we
are just over a minute in and in case
you were confused on what I was talking
about this is kind of what it looks look
like you just run up buy them Bank them
run up buy them and Bank them all right
I will be back all right I couldn't be
bothered to do an hour of this so I'm
almost at 30 minutes and that is when
I'm going to stop so let's see how many
inventories we can get in these last
minutes actually this last 30
seconds can we get one
more yep just in time okay it's been 30
minutes now I will price check okay now
it is time to price check
them we bought a total of 2,667 in 30
minutes so we will do the
304k 38 minus the total cost of buying
all them which was
2,451 and that's
282k 587 * 2
565k so you can make almost 600k an hour
doing this method it takes little to no
effort as you just run back and forth
and buy the copper ores it's a very easy
money-making guide and I hope you guys
like it additionally I'm going to be
making a blast furnace guide with the
new update so look forward to that and
thanks for watching guys stay tuned for
my next
video